لقد أثر kovat 19 تقريبًا على كل
جانب من جوانب الحياة الأمريكية ، وهذا
يشمل سعر اللحوم الذي
لم أره بالتأكيد شيئًا كهذا
في أسعار لحوم البقر طوال حياتي عند مستوى ملح O
أو مرتفعًا كما سجلناه وقمت
بتسجيل البيانات لذلك هذا بالتأكيد
شيء  بعيدًا عن المألوف
لفهم ما يحدث وأين
يمكن أن تتجه أسعار اللحوم ، نحتاج إلى
فهم سلسلة توريد اللحوم
عادةً ما يقوم المزارعون بتربية الماشية
حتى يصلوا إلى وزنهم في السوق ، ثم
يرسلونها إلى مصانع المعالجة
أو المسالخ حيث يتم
قتل الحيوانات  ويتم ذبحه في قطعتين من
اللحم يتم إرسالهما بعد ذلك إلى الموزعين
والوسطاء الذين يبيعون المنتج بعد ذلك إلى
مطاعم السوبر ماركت وغيرهم في
صناعة الخدمات الغذائية حيث
يشتري المستهلكون الأمريكيون عادة اللحوم بهذه
الطريقة تعمل في ظل الظروف العادية
ولكن أثناء الوباء  تشكل عنق الزجاجة
هنا في مصانع المعالجة
والذي سيصبح نقطة ساخنة
لتفشي COBIT 19 ، وهناك مخاوف جديدة  فوق
مرافق تعبئة اللحوم حيث
يستمر العمال في الحصول على أكثر من 150 عاملاً ، أكثر
من 800 عامل في المصنع ثبتت
إصابتهم بالفيروس ،
مما تسبب في إبطاء العديد من المصانع
أو إغلاقها بالكامل نتيجة
لقدرة إنتاج لحوم البقر والخنازير في الولايات المتحدة.
انخفض بنسبة 40 في المائة في أبريل
مقارنة بالعام الماضي ،
وكان لذلك الانخفاض المفاجئ والدراماتيكي آثار متتالية
عبر سلسلة التوريد ، فإن
قدرة المعالجة الوطنية في جميع
المصانع في الولايات المتحدة تبلغ حوالي
500 ألف رطل في اليوم ، لذا إذا كنت
تعمل بنسبة 42 في المائة أقل من طاقتها
هذا يعني أن هناك ما يقرب من 200000
خنزير إضافي سنذهب إلى السوق التي
لا تزال عالقة في المزرعة إذا قمت
بتشغيلها بنسبة 40 في المائة أقل من طاقتها لمدة خمسة
أيام وهو ما فعلناه ، فهذا يعني أن مليون
خنزير إضافي كان سيذهب إلى
السوق ولكن بدلاً من ذلك  بقيت في المزرعة
التي تركت العديد من مزارعي الخنازير يواجهون
قرارًا مفجعًا لأنك
تنظر إلى 3500 خنزير من المحتمل
أن يتم قتلها بطريقة رحمة ،
فهذا ليس شيئًا نحن مدربون على القيام به ،
إنه بالتأكيد شيء لا نريد
القيام به في النهاية  كانت النتيجة أن عددًا أقل من
الخنازير والأبقار يدخلون
المسالخ مما يعني أن اللحوم
تشق طريقها إلى محلات البقالة مما
أدى إلى نقص اللحوم في جميع أنحاء البلاد.
أدى النقص الكبير في الأسعار
إلى ارتفاع الأسعار بشكل واضح عندما نتحدث
عن نقص اللحوم ولكن هذا لا يعني أن
متجرك المحلي سينفد من اللحوم
ولكن قد لا تجد التنوع أو
الأسعار التي اعتدت عليها عندما تنظر
في هذه الأسعار الإرشادية الكاملة للحوم البقر
ولحم الخنزير ، فإنهم يزيدون عن ضعف
ما كانوا عليه قبل شهر ، وهذا لا
يعني بالضرورة مضاعفة أسعار التجزئة
ولكن هناك تضخم في
الطريق للمستهلكين سوف يقرض بنك النشر
للناس و  الشركات العاملة في
صناعة البروتين الحيواني ، يتوقع
أن ترتفع أسعار لحوم الأبقار هذا الصيف بنسبة 20٪ وأن تكون أسعار لحوم
الخنازير أعلى مقارنة بعام
2019 في محاولة للتخفيف من عنق الزجاجة ،
أصدر الرئيس ترامب أمرًا تنفيذيًا
يصنف مصانع معالجة اللحوم
كبنية تحتية مركزية
تسمح بـ  الحكومة لإجبار المصانع على
البقاء مفتوحة ويبدو أن الأمور قد
بدأت في تحسين الطاقة الإنتاجية
انتعشت إلى حوالي 75 ٪ في مايو
مقارنة بالعام السابق ولكن جزءًا من
سبب توقف المصانع  لا يزالون يعملون
بأقل من طاقتهم الكاملة ، لأنهم
لا يزالون خائفين للغاية من العودة إلى
داخل المصانع حتى
يتم فتح عنق الزجاجة تمامًا وقد يخرج بعض المزارعين
عن العمل مما يعني
أن نقص اللحوم وارتفاع الأسعار قد
يستمر لأشهر في الوقت الحالي
يتوقع سوير أن المزارعين المعروفين أيضًا باسم
المنتجين سيخسرون ما بين 20 إلى 25 مليار
دولار هذا العام أنهم يخسرون أموالًا
إلى درجة لم نشهدها حتى
خلال فترة الركود العظيم التي
ستؤدي إلى خروج بعض المنتجين من
الصناعة ومن الواضح أن هذا الإنتاج
قد يعود أو لا ، ولكن في
غضون ذلك ، سنرى انخفاضًا في
إمدادات اللحوم وسيتعين على بيئة
المستهلك أن تشهد المزيد من التضخم على
الأرجح نتيجة لذلك
[موسيقى]